sur une civière c'est par cette image
inédite que s'est ouvert le procès
d'hosni moubarak au caire le dictateur
déchu a comparé vêtus de blanc et
allongé dans la cage des accusés
il a plaidé non coupable au cours d'une
audience assez courte et ajourné au 15
août prochain bernard le bras c'est une
incroyable image que beaucoup en egypte
10 est impensable
l'ex président déchu dans un box
d'accusés derrière les barreaux sous les
caméras y portant l'uniforme blanc des
détenus qui plus est faible parce qu'il
refuse de s'alimenter s'est allongé sur
une civière qu'hosni moubarak 83 ans a
comparu lui le dernier pharaon comme
l'appelaient ses partisans président
sans partage de l'egypte pendant 29 ans
l'instant est historique
évidemment diffusé en direct par la
chaîne publique égyptienne
la télévision moubarak hier le président
déchu le premier dirigeant du
moyen-orient à comparaître en personne
depuis le début du printemps arabe
c'est un tribunal civil qui le juge
l'acte d'accusation est sans détour
corruption complicité d'homicide
volontaire en clair assassinat de 840
manifestants les accusés encourent la
peine capitale
le juge interroge alors l'accusé malade
mais combatif
nubarak répond dans le même box alaa et
gamal moubarak ses deux fils accusés des
mêmes crimes
gamal au micro se rêvait en successeur
de son père le voici réduit en simple
détenus plaidant non-coupable comme les
autres près d'eux assis sur un banc
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
souvenirs
c'est lui qui est accusé d'avoir donné
l'ordre aux policiers d'ouvrir le feu
sur la foule
en janvier dernier pour lui la peine
capitale est demandée puis soudainement
fin d'audience le juge annonce que le
président déchu restera dans un hôpital
au caire et renvoie le procès au 15 août
dehors devant cette école de police
transformée en tribunal partisans et
opposants de moubarak se sont affrontés
pendant toute la matinée
c'est dans ce contexte politique fébrile
que ce procès historique s'est ouvert
aux quarts
[Musique]